من صنعاء ينضم الينا نصر الدين عامر نائب
رئيس الهيئه الاعلاميه لجماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين اهلا بك سيد نصر الدين عامر ما
الرساله من وراء استهداف سفينه في البحر
الاحمر تعود ملكيتها للولايات
المتحده نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في
التفاصيل عن ما حدث سيصدر بيان للمتحدث
الرسمي للقوات المسلحه بعد قليل واما
بالنسبه للاطار العام فنحن تحدث عن
استمرار العمليات ضد كيان العدو
الاسرائيلي وايضا نستطيع ان نقول باننا
وصلنا الى مرحله او على اعتاب ان تفقد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
امها الملاحي في البحر الاحمر والبحر
العربي
ويعني بسبب توريط على اليمن هي وبريطانيا
هذا هو الاطار الطبيعي لهذه العمليات و
اما بالنسبه
للاسرائيليين هو عدم السماء للملاحه للسفن
الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى اسرائيل حتى
يتوقف العدوان على غزه ولكن هل كانت هذه
السفينه متجهه الى اسرائيل ام انكم بصدد
توسيع بنك الاهداف لتشمل ايضا السفن
الامريكيه والبريطانيه بعد الغارات التي
تعرضت لها
اليمن بعد الغارات التي تعرضت لها اليمن
ليس بالضروره ان تكون هذه السفينه متجهه
الى اسرائيل يكفي ان تكون امريكيه تابعه
للامريكي الذي استهدف بلدنا واستباح سماءه
ودم وقصف اهداف في اليمن وانتهك السياده
اليمنيه وهو كما قلنا سابقا يستحق الرد
ونحن ملتزمون بالرد فليس بالضروره ان تكون
متجهه الى اسرائيل اها وهذا سيشمل جميع
السفن الامريكيه والبريطانيه التي ستمر في
تلك
المنطقه لا استطيع ان اقول بانه سيشمل
جميعها ام لا ولكنها اصبحت اداف مشروعه
يعني امريكا جزئيا نقول او على اعتاب ان
تفقد امنها الملاحي في هذه البحرين
المهمين البحر العربي والبحر الاحمر خاصه
ان العمليه يبدو لي انها جرت في البحر
العربي وليس في البحر الاحمر طيب القياده
الوسطى الامريكيه السيد نصر الدين عامر
تقول ان
القصف قصف جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين لهذه
السفينه لم يؤدي لم يصبها اساسا ولم يؤدي
الى اضرار فيها هل يضعف هذا الامر من
الرساله التي تريدون توجيهها
ابدا هو يحاول ان ان يقلل ولكن يعني في
نهايه المطاف السفن لن تصمد امام يعني
الصواريخ البالستيه لا يوجد سفن ستبحر
بامان وهي تتوقع ان يصيبها صاروخ بالستي
وتعتبر ذلك امرا عاديا يعني المساله ليست
بالضروره ان تكون السفينه ان تغرق ولكن ان
تصاب بصاروخ بالستي هذا سيشكل مشكله هذا
ما فعلته ويجب ان يعرف الشعب الامريكي ان
هذا ما فعلته الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عندما جاءت لدعم كيان العدو الاسرائيلي
الذي يقتل النساء والاطفال لقد فداء وخدمه
للصهاينه ضحت بامن الملاحه الامريكيه و
يعني والحقت الضرر بالاسعار للمواطن
الامريكي الذي يدفع الضرائب لهذه الاداره
والتي تقول بانها صهيونيه وجاءت لخدمه
الصهاينه وفعلت مشكله ستسبب في اضرار
بامداد الطاقه وامدادات الوجود للامريكيين
سيد نصر الدين عمر لكن الولايات المت
متحده وبريطانيا تتوعد
بان الغارات والضربات التي وجهتها لجماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين ستتكرر في حال
كررت الهجمات على السفن في البحر الاحمر
كيف ستتعامل مع
ذلك ونحن نتوعد بان ضرباتنا ستستمر وبان
ردنا سيستمر نحن لسنا ممن يستقبل الضربات
من عدوه ويسكت هذا غير وارد في ادبيات ولا
في فكرنا الثقافي والديني ولا في السياسي
نحن فكرنا يقول انه من يضربنا سنضربه ومن
يعتدي علينا نعتدي عليه ومن اعتدى عليكم
فاعتدوا عليه بمثل ما اعتدى عليه ولكن هل
يتحمل اليمن مثل هكذا ضربات وهل تتحمل
اصلا البنيه التحتيه العسكريه لديكم مثل
هكذا ضربات من جيش مثل جيش الامريكي
والجيش
البريطاني بالنسبه للشعب اليمني مطالب
اعلى من هذا السقف ما زال يطالب بمزيد من
العمليات واكثر من هذه العمليات دعم للشعب
الفلسطيني وهو يقول بانه مستعد ان يتحمل
النتائج كل الفرقاء في اليمن يقولون ذلك
اما بالنسبه للبنيه العسكريه نحن بنيتنا
العسكريه هي بنيت في ظل عدوان خارجي اي
انها ليست بنيه متاحه ومكشوفه بل هي في
حاله تموضع مخفي نتيجه يعني تاسيسها تحت
وطاه عدوان كبير وتحت غارات الطيران يعني
انها مهيئه لمثل هذه الظروف ولاصعب من هذه
الظروف الان هناك تحذيرات دوليه من ضروره
عدم اتساع رقعه الصراع وتحديدا في البحر
الاحمر دخول الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
على الخط الا تخشون انه
سيعمق المشكله وانه ربما قد
يقلب بلدان جارى لكم في المنطقه على ما
تقومون
به
امريكا من تتحمل المسؤوليه وهي من عسكرا
البحر اما نحن ف عملياتنا مستمره منذ مده
ولم تستهدف احد ولم نتضرر منها احد دول
الجوار لم تتضرر من عملياتنا حتى جاءت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا
وعسكر هذه المنطقه وشنت الحروب وشكلت
التحالفات لارباك المشهد وللضغط على دول
المنطقه والاضرار بدول المنطقه واذا هي من
تتحمل اما نحن فنقوم بمسؤوليتنا تجاه
الشعب الفلسطيني ومسانده الشعب الفلسطيني
وهذه المسؤوليه ليست علينا وحدنا بل هي
علينا وعلى دول الجوار يجب ان يكون جزءا
من هذه العمليات واذا لم يستطيعوا ان
يكونوا جزءا من هذه العمليات يجب ان
يعرفوا من الذي يريد ان يضر بهم ويضر بنا
جميعا ويضر بالشعب الفلسطيني اولا وهو
الامريكي والبريطاني الذين مستعدون ان
يضحوا بالمنطقه وبام الملاحه وبشعبه من
اجل الصهاينه ولكن هم لديهم وجهه نظر اخرى
يقولون ان ما يجري من قبلكم
هو خرق للقانون الدولي واستهداف للملاحه
الدوليه وهل القتل الشعب الفلسطيني رجع
يعني للقانون الدولي اذا كانوا يسمونه
خرقا فماذا نسمي الجرائم التي تحدث في
فلسطين هم لا يحترمون لا قانون دولي ولا
اعراف ولا امور انسانيه ولا اخلاقيه ولا
قيميه لا يحترمون شيء ونحن نساند الشعب
الفلسطيني من منظر اخلاقي وديني وانساني
اشكرك نصر الدين عامر نائب رئيس الهيئه
الاعلاميه لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
ضيفنا من
صنعاء